cette libération marque non pas le terme
mais une étape cruciale dans cette
affaire criminelle où subsistent tant de
zones d'ombré tour en arrière avec
dominique verdeilhan et valérie un mythe
je suis innocent c'est le seul mot
qu'omar raddad a prononcé en français
durant son procès à nice en 94
quelques heures plus tard les jurés de
la cour d'assises en prononcer un autre
coupable omar raddad été condamné à 18
ans de réclusion criminelle pour le
meurtre de ghislaine marchal
il ya cent ans condamné un jeune
officier qui avait le tort d'être juifs
aujourd'hui on condamne en jardinier
parce qu'il a le tort d'être maghrébin
le 23 juin 1991 le corps de ghislaine
marchal est retrouvée exemple dans la
cave de sa villa de mougins pour les
gendarmes l'enquète s'annonce facile la
victime a désigné le coupable du bout
des doigts sur deux porte une
inscription en lettres de sang omar m'a
tuer 1er
le jardinier marocain est arrêté le
mobile selon l'accusation son employeur
lui aurait refusé de lui avancer de
l'argent
omar raddad coupable idéal résultat
aucune empreinte n'a été relevé enfin le
corps de madame marchal a été incinéré
très rapidement en empêchant ainsi tout
contre expertise au lendemain du procès
les intellectuels se mobilisent à leur
tête
l'écrivain jean marie rouart croyez vous
que ces écrivains comme ça se soit
décidé à la légère c'était bien les
vidéos que pour les gens qui étudient un
peu cette question c'est évident omar
est innocent omar n'a pas tué il suffit
de voir de suivre les nombreuses
invraisemblances
pendant que certains font des livres les
détectives eux mènent leur enquête
parallèle apparaît ainsi un second omar
fausse piste
au maroc un ex-détenu innocente omar
s'en suit un graphologue sollicité par
maître vergès termine son rapport par
ces mots mal à marshall n'est pas
l'auteur des inscriptions en question
hier un privée affirmait je cite les
vrais coupables sont deux italiens et
une femme seul point marqué par omar
raddad en 96 jacques chirac par une
grâce avait allégé sa peine de prison de
quatre ans